hey guys Mary and Dan here at TGIF 2016
and you wouldn't believe it but Call of
Duty is here but maybe not the way you
think it's jackal Assault a vr game
that's actually free when you buy
infinite warfare on ps4
that's correct and you got to play it
the butt blade in VR but how did it go
not so hot now I'm really really new to
VR and I found myself so sick after I
think I played it for I think maybe 5-10
minutes at the most and it may be
halfway through my stomach just roll
because basically how its set up is
you're in The Jackal which is the the
spaceship your assault ship I guess from
a quality infinite warfare and it's you
see you're sitting there you can see
your shoulders you can see your body and
you've got two sticks you know throttle
up and all this stuff but you're aiming
reticle for your machine gun is tied to
your right stick aiming and the aiming
for your missiles is tied to your head
movements and it just felt really
strange and hard to kind of for me to in
my mind make sense of those two things
to happen and something about halfway
trails I was looking at a ship over here
and I'll shooting at something over here
and all of a sudden it was just almost
game over I just little green I thought
I was going to throw up it was really
bad it looks fantastic there's a great
part where you fly out of the hangar and
it feels like you get the sensation that
you are moving ridiculously quickly it's
this great trick of you know your mind
and and your eyes working together this
your create this illusion the churches
pulling like 10 G's out of a space
station and just going straight out into
a space and all that stuff's very cool
you can fly under these gigantic
spaceships which look amazing but that's
just something about I don't know if it
was me or if it was just that those two
aiming reticles but I just just felt so
bad and that's a shame too because like
this is a free game absolutely were the
people to enjoy about maybe not for
people who yeah totally anyone who can
get maudlin motion sick I think maybe
steer clear of this one but it's great
so I'd give it a go at please well Dan
thanks for talking to me about Call of
Duty Jackal assault and
everything else TGS you guys are gonna
stay tuned to game spot
you